[Music]
this morning we remember the remarkable
life of an opera singer we first met
about seven years ago her family tells
us
charity Tillerman dick died Tuesday
morning in addition to her celebrated
voice the singer was also a champion of
organ donation
she received not one but two sets of
transplanted lungs Seth Doane shows us
how that allowed her to continue doing
what she was born to do opera is hard
enough to master nevermind the charity
Tilghman dick was singing with lungs
that were not her own when I go into a
stage and when I sing it makes me so
happy because I'm I'm sharing one of the
things I value most we first met back in
2012 at the prestigious Cleveland Clinic
where we scrubbed in to talk with the
singer after her second double lung
transplant she showed us her therapy
sessions and her sense of humor
she'd always loved to sing but by about
age 20 developed something called
idiopathic pulmonary hypertension which
is when oxygen is not properly absorbed
by the body and forces the heart to work
over time she had her first emergency
lung transplant in 2009 and later needed
another after her body started to reject
the lungs how is the wait for a
transplant every time the phone rings
you you hope that maybe maybe they've
found a match after being placed on
advanced life support they found a donor
organ donation in certain respects it
brings us closer to immortality because
literally a part of us goes on living
after after we're gone live
and sing she did dr. Jon LaPook met her
several years later after Tillman dick
wrote a book about her experiences and
held a special performance with the
daughter of her lung donor do you have a
relationship with your donor through
your lungs do you feel you're giving her
voice well I think she gives me voice
family says humor got her through the th
of our dreams to to spend our lives with
the people with the things that we love
most and so I'm so grateful to be given
another opportunity to sing and to share
and it brings me more joy than I can
express and I express a lot of things so
that's saying something she often went
by the name charity sunshine her husband
wrote she passed away with family by her
side and sunshine on her face for CBS
this morning
Seth Dome that's a beautiful thing to
say passed away with sunshine on her
face and she went through so much - I
remember when Seth did that story I'd
never heard of her before but what a
beautiful voice I'm so very sad to hear
that news